this is a major major story and it's not
getting nearly the attention that it
needs we've talked about the problem of
police militarization before major
problem in the United States local
police departments getting armored
vehicles and grenade launchers and all
sorts of military equipment now a couple
years ago President Obama actually
issued an executive order backward when
those were bad and anti-democratic now
under Trump executive orders are good
but you know that back then executive
orders were bad because it was Obama
doing them Obama's executive order
banned the transfer of lots of military
type equipment to local police
departments after the unrest we saw in
Ferguson Missouri Donald Trump is going
to be rolling back those limits and that
is going to reopen the door to even more
police militarization and Attorney
General Jeff Sessions actually spoke
about the rollback of this this ban at
the yearly conference of the Fraternal
Order of Police in Nashville Tennessee
very friendly crowd to Jeff Sessions
multiple standing ovations very very
scary stuff and here's part of what Jeff
Sessions said in explaining the rollback
of this ban he said we are fighting a
multi-front battle an increase in
violent crime not true crime is down
arise in vicious gangs an opioid
epidemic threats from terrorism combined
with a culture in which family and
discipline seem to be eroding further
and a disturbing disrespect for the rule
of law the executive order the president
will sign today will ensure that you can
get the life-saving gear that you need
to do your job and send a strong message
that we will not allow criminal activity
violence and lawlessness to become the
new normal the opioid crisis the opioid
crisis is on the list of reasons that
Jeff Sessions believes local police need
to be more militarized he cites a
culture in which family and discipline
seems to be eroding as part of why local
police should be militarized how do
tanks in the streets bring families
together how are we better off with
armored vehicles driven by camouflage
wearing police officers with shoulder
mounted grenade launchers
in our cities and towns and again he
cites this increase in violent crime
violent crime is down big in the United
States in the last 30 years and you can
find some specific cities where during a
specific two or three year period in the
last decade there's been somewhat of an
increase in violent crime but the trend
continues violent crime is down
significantly in the United States and
underlying this there's probably nothing
about Donald Trump's philosophy on the
police that's leading him to do this it
might be as simple as this vendetta
against President Obama and just trying
to overturn anything that Barack Obama
did I don't know Pat that we're really
learning anything here about Donald
Trump's philosophy on law enforcement he
just wants to undo anything Obama did
that maybe so and I think if there was
ever a time to rollback police
militarization it would be now
considering I mean the incidents in
Ferguson and around the country but also
just because violent crime is down so
much and if they're not going to
advocate for that now when the time is
most opportune they're never going to do
it and it just goes to this idea that
you know the military-industrial complex
is just something that's going to be
perpetual because this is really the
last leg of it trying to get the last
dollars you can out of it by selling a
lot of that equipment back to the police
the some is being sold some is being
given away in the defense of some of
these police departments but I decided
to be thorough so I looked into well are
there studies that tell us what happens
in cities and towns or counties where
you see more police militarization and
there's actually a study about this it's
called police officer on the front line
or a soldier the effect of police
militarization on crime and it's been
published in the American economic
journal the headline is hey when you
give military aid to local police
you see lower crime rates which strikes
what US as wow that that's interesting
how is that gonna work and when you look
at the study and a lot of people that
like police militarization point to this
study they don't really understand it
military aid according to this study
includes everything from lawn non-lethal
crowd dispersal equipment to office
supplies if it comes from the military
it's considered military aid so that
doesn't really say anything about how
grenade launchers
reduce crime or have a deterrant
deterrent effect what it tells us is
police departments that generally have
more resources correlate with decreases
in crime and that is not a defense for
tart tanks in the streets as controlled
by police departments last thought on
this what I will never understand and
maybe you can explain it to me Pat maybe
someone in the audience can explain it
to me how is it that many of the same
people that say we need guns to protect
ourselves from a potentially tyrannical
government want the police having bigger
and badder weapons isn't that gonna make
it more likely that the government could
become tyrannical which is something
you're trying to protect yourself
against I don't get it it's this real
cognitive dissonance where they think
that the government is purely about
politicians and not so much the folks on
the ground these also are the people who
will support the police no matter what
yeah and are susceptible to
fear-mongering and I think that's
exactly what Trump and sessions are
trying to do here well think about the
big picture right Trump backs a heavily
armed all right he says there are very
fine people among a neo-nazi protesters
still haven't gotten a list of those
fine people that are the neo-nazi
protesters and he wants local police to
be more heavily armed add it to the list
of the move towards authoritarianism you
can discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash read it today's episode made
possible by taga dabbe the hosting
specialist taga dab offers a range of
flexible hosting packages including
dedicated VPS and cloud server options
they also do custom server solutions and
colocation services taga dab has a
really user-friendly interface and
excellent customer support team their
expert hosting specialists also are
their friendly support team and they
give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving there
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dad is offering you as a david
pakman show viewer or listener a twenty
British Pound free credits about twenty
four US dollars to all new customers
signing up to give you a chance to try
their services to take advantage of it
go to sign up tag adapt calm /td PS for
more information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up tag adapt comm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS
20